Um I don't believe that Allah in Islam
fits the criterias of being God.
>> Okay, perfect. Um so we should establish
some characteristics of who God is,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> For example, being the necessary being
who sustains the universe and um what
other attributes would you like to put
into?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think that's good. uh self
self- sustaining and self-sufficient all
powerful all knowing
um um you know morally perfect I think
that these are qualities of who and what
god is
>> I I believe that Allah doesn't doesn't
fit uh fulfill the criteria of being all
powerful and self-sufficient
>> okay um
why is that do you have any
any verses that you would like to point
out or
>> Yeah.
Yeah. So, um let me ask you this cuz I I
hear this about like this is a big topic
when it comes to Allah about him having
children. Would Allah be able to have a
son if he wanted to?
>> Well, I I've seen a video I've seen the
video in which he talked about this with
a Muslim girl. Um, but I think your
argument misses kind of the point of of
the verse because you said that that was
a response towards a polytheistic
religion. Well, in those religions, they
understood of being a god as
well being having a son as something
that is similar to how we as humans
conceive a um a son. So he was basically
saying how can he have a son b
theologically if he uh doesn't have a
wife and so can he do it would you agree
with me? Um, yeah, he can. I mean,
>> he can.
>> Yeah, he he could, obviously.
>> So, okay. So, so he so he can have a
son.
>> He he can have a son if he wanted. Um,
and you're saying accord in response to
6 verse 101. He can do it by himself. He
can have a son by himself. He doesn't
need a wife to have a son.
>> Well, it depends on what do you mean by
that? because
it depends on what do we mean by by son
I don't want to get into the semantics
of it but it is kind of important to
note that if we by so we mean in the
biological sense that we mean with
humans that's kind of a different
conversation because by definition with
humans we need two beings to
uh to have that
>> and that's what it seems like Allah
argues too it seems like he argues that
in order for him to have a son he need
another being to have a son with.
>> Well, not necessarily because well, I I
guess you can point out to the fact that
in the Quran um there is the one of
saying that he neither beasts nor is
born.
Well, I mean that is kind of
uh I don't know what they just did here,
but I mean it's just that
Yeah, because either you beget something
or you make something, right? When you
when you put something into creation,
either you beget it or you make it,
right?
>> Just one second. Sorry, Tik Tok is
saying that there's uh people on Tik
Tok, can you guys hear us? Can you hear
him when he's talking?
>> So, there's a lag. It's fine. Okay.
Okay, we're good.
>> Good.
>> We're all good. Okay. So, Okay. Good.
Good. Good. So, um yeah. So, in 6101, he
says, "How can he have a son when he
doesn't have a mate?" Right. So, he's
arguing that he would need a mate in
order to have a son. He doesn't have a
mate. So therefore you can't accuse him
of having a son, right?
>> Well ju just for asking that question
like uh is there any type of context
that we can have from that uh verse that
is important to note?
>> Yeah, the context is that they're saying
that Allah has sons that he has children
and this is his response to that.
>> Okay. It's but who who's saying it?
>> Who's saying what? That he has sons.
>> That he has sons. Yeah. early pagans.
>> Oh yeah. Um so again like the way a son
is defined in those religions at least
the way they understood it and the way
they
>> why did Allah respond to them in a way
that they understand like in a way that
they know how you have kids. Why does
Allah apply their understanding to
himself?
>> Well I guess because you have to meet
people where they are. For example, even
even in your Bible, for example,
sometimes Jes uh Jesus or uh will uses
parables to explain things even if they
aren't
like say they would not be totally
accurate but in their own understanding
it will be that way. Would you agree?
>> How about the Now the parables that
Jesus uses corrects the understanding.
If people have a false understanding,
he'll use a parable to correct a false
understanding. It seems like what you're
saying is that they have a false
understanding of of Allah. However,
Allah uses their understanding and
applies it to himself. So why would he
do that if their understanding is wrong
from the from the from the jump?
>> Well, no. I I'm just saying that they
interpreting the word of having a son in
a different way that well, they were
asking a specific question in the sense
of they were intending son in a way that
Allah wasn't.
So, let me get this straight.
They say that Allah has children. His
response is, "How can I have children?
How can I have a son when I don't have a
mate?"
Right? So, he's refuting their claim
that he has children cuz he doesn't have
a mate to have children with. Are we
clear on that?
>> Uh, wait. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I think I think it's logically
consistent.
>> Okay. So, he's refuting their claim of
him having a son by saying he doesn't
have a mate to have a son with in the
first place. Refuting them. So, they
need to stop saying he has children cuz
he doesn't have anybody to have children
with. So if that's not the the correct
understanding,
why would Allah use that to refute their
claim that he has a son? If their
understanding of how he has sons in the
first place is just wrong already.
>> Well, um I just have four words which is
I do not know. like honestly
>> it so it wouldn't make sense that he's
just speaking in a way that they
understand to help them or whatever cuz
that that just wouldn't that would bring
more confusion cuz that doesn't refu
like imagine if if that doesn't um if
that doesn't pertain to Allah having a
mate to have kids if that doesn't
pertain to Allah then that reputation is
pointless
they can still say that he has children
without a mate then but he uses that to
refute them. So it's showing that this
actually does go for Allah and he can't
have a son unless he has another being
to have a son with.
Well, I guess
uh so basically the argument is that
they're making the objection, but the
objection well yeah maybe the objection
is just not valid because the
understanding of who Allah is is yeah
because there is the verse that says
that he does not beget. Um, I wonder if
that already implies the fact that he's
not all powerful because
>> Yeah, it it it was it would mean he's
not all powerful because he's he's
saying that in order to do something, he
would need another being. So, he's he
can't self-sufficiently
provide a son. He would need help to
provide a son.
Well um
so we just to know we rest on the Quran
only right in this debate.
>> Yeah.
>> But I will just say that um like in the
definition who on who Allah is. Allah is
say he is Allah who is one. Allah the
eternal refugee. He neither begats nor
is born nor is there to him any
equivalent. So I think that in the at
least in Muhammad's understanding
um he's saying that he does not beget
because it is something that applies
only to creation
but it doesn't seem like that
because he applies something to creation
to himself needing a mate to have a son
just like creation needs a mate to have
a son Allah also needs a mate to have a
son.
Right.
>> So he's not all powerful.
>> Um
unless you go into the what really to
means because if he has a son that has
the same essence, can he really be one?
>> Yeah, he can be one in essence just
multiple persons that share that same
essence,
>> right? But well a person describes what
something is whereas
>> No, an essence is your essence.
>> Essence is what what
>> No, I mean your essence is what
something is.
>> Yeah. Your essence
>> is how that relates.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Your your person is who is
who something is.
>> Yep. Um, well, I guess that the only
thing I can do is to agree with you
because if I were to make an argument
out of basically nothing would mean not
be at least honestly
like intellectually honest.
>> I appreciate that.
>> That's humble. So, so for now then I
guess I it is fair for me to hold to be
at least for now it's it's fair for me
to conclude that because of this it
logically follows that Allah is not all
powerful. At least for now, maybe until
somebody can bring something else or
maybe a better answer.
>> Unless you can show that having a son is
logical,
>> but it doesn't seem like it is. At least
in my understanding.
>> Well, Allah, do you believe that uh God
can do illogical things?
>> No. Exactly. And if having a son would
be illogical, then therefore it would be
logical to assume that God does not have
a son. Right. Allah says he can have a
son if he want it.
>> I guess that's the dilemma then.
>> Dilemma. How many dilemas?
>> Another Islamic dilemma.
>> I've seen I've seen the absent dilemma.
Like I saw that you put the
the the link in there and I was showing
it to my friends. They were they were
listening to to these guys defending
yeah Aisha's marriage and everything on
the train cuz we were getting on on a
trip for school cuz I'm in high school
>> and
um and they were like horrified and I
was like
>> well I was kind of expecting it. So
yeah, I guess that's the the one thing
that I would not say that Muslim because
throughout your videos and Sam, you
know, I kind of can see the the problems
in the logic.
>> So wait, so you're a Muslim, right?
Well, not exactly, especially after this
conversation, but I was looking into it
and I was like trying to get all the
understanding first, you know.
>> I see. So, so now Islam is you're
marking it off. You're exing it off the
page.
>> Yeah.
>> Praise God. That's good.
>> Can I make a question?
>> Sure.
>> Make a question. Yeah.
>> Um, like I've seen this thing about the
about Jesus and how he can't be God
because he's a human being and God and
the two the two things are technically
um logically exclusive because one is
limited by definition being human is
limited whereas being God is illitim and
well I got some responses but I just
didn't get them like probably because
I'm smart enough but like yeah
>> no you're smart enough it's okay just uh
need need more clarification so you're
you're asking how can Jesus be God when
he's a man but also but also be God at
the same time when being God means that
you're unlimited being man is you are
limited is that right
>> well yes and also like necessary and um
like God is by definition necessary and
being human is nec is uh by definition
being contingent.
>> Mhm. Yeah. So
>> things
>> Yeah. So the the con so this is what is
called the the hypoatic union. It's
>> right and uh so it's it's when the
person of Christ uh has two natures that
are united in in his person.
>> So he has two distinct he has a divine
nature. He also has a human nature. And
these two natures are not mixed. meaning
so like the human nature doesn't dilute
the divine nature or vice versa. He's
fully God and fully man at the same time
and those natures are united in his
person.
So um it's not that we're saying that he
is uh self-sufficient and also
contingent in the same way in the same
sense he's self-sufficient via his
divine nature right and via his
humanity. his human because his humanity
was created, right? It was he was born
at some point. His humanity was
contingent. So that's another sense,
another way.
So would it be fair to say that he is
man and God at the same time? like just
I wouldn't say in two different times
>> because it's not the right way to say it
>> but but yeah he's he is both fully man
and fully God you know and and it's at
the same like it's not like when he
takes on when he comes to earth and
takes on humanity enters flesh takes on
the human nature his divine nature
doesn't disappear he's still divine he
still possesses the full divine essence
and see he just also takes on another
nature as the human nature,
>> right? So, he just it's like water and
oil. Like
>> water and oil.
>> They just don't mix.
>> They just don't mix. You put them in the
same
>> cup, but they just don't mix.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Exactly.
So, does that make a little bit more
sense with Is that a little bit more
clear when it comes to Jesus?
Well, yeah, but I mean I mean trying to
understand God isn't easy. So
>> absolutely right be fair to not be able
to understand it fully.
>> Exactly. Exactly. So man, you're you're
you're uh it seems like you're you're
honest and you're you're looking into
things, which is beautiful, which is
good, man. So I'm glad that we were able
to ex Islam off your list,
you know, get that out the way. Um, but
yeah, if you have if you have any more
questions, man, about Christianity, you
want to come up and ask, um, you can
definitely keep coming up and asking,
bro. It's all good. Okay.
>> All right.
>> All right. It was very nice talking to
you. How do you, how do I say your name?
Is it Is it Chesure?
>> Ches. Um, or you can go by what it's
like with Imper Caesar.
>> Caesar.
>> For sure. For sure. Well, God bless you,
man. You asked some good questions
today, man.
>> Yeah. No. Okay. I try to like at least
>> give an honest response which I saw that
in these lives is not
>> Yep. Ex. Exactly.
>> It's not common. That's just
>> Exactly. All right. God bless you, man.
Talk to you soon.
>> All right. Good blessing.
>> Peace.
>> Good life. Peace.
>> Let's bring in a sunchild. How you
doing?
>> Hey.
>> Hey. You a Muslim?
>> Uh I'm a former Christian. I'm uh
considering Islam. Uh, but I have a
couple of a question that can help me
out uh with regards to what your
conversation is tonight if I may.
>> What what's making you consider Islam?
>> Uh, well, I'm I'm currently in limbo.
Like I said, I've recent I've left uh
Christianity and I'm uh sort of in limbo
as far as uh where to go spiritually.
>> Yeah. Why would you go to Islam?
>> Well, I'm I'm interested in this in this
conversation with regards to a couple of
subjects that I've been considering with
Islam myself, and I was hoping you could
help clarify for me.
>> Okay.
uh with regards to um the Quran and um
whether it confirms the Bible, right?
I'm hearing you saying that uh
>> yeah,
>> the Quran confirms the Bible is correct,
which in effect makes if the Quran
contradicts the Bible, then it is
incorrect.
>> That's right. Uh now my question for you
is uh I I've come to understand that the
the gospel or the angel as far as the
Quran is concerned they were
um open to and had access to the
Apocrypha gospels.
And in these apocrypha gospels, they do
make reference to the
uh um Jesus not being crucified but
being making it appear as such. I
believe it's the gospel of Thomas.
>> Gospel of Thomas came came way after
Muhammad.
>> Okay. Um and there's the gospel of the
Ebianites. I I appreciate that and I'll
have to look for uh further into that.
The gospel of the Ebianites with respect
to Jesus not being the son of God.
Um there are also
>> where wait hold on. Where is this gospel
of the Ebianites?
Well, it's I'm hoping you can uh you can
shed light on it is the research that
I've done uh not great research, but I
understand that there's a gospel of the
Ebianites, which is uh early
Jewish/Christianity
>> believe that Jesus was not the son of
God.
>> There's no gospel of the Ebianites.
>> That that does not exist.
>> No.
>> Um let's see. How about um are and
you're saying the gospel of Thomas comes
after the seventh the sixth and seventh
century?
>> Yep. That the Gospel of Thomas is a is a
15th century forgery between the 13th
and 15th century.
>> Okay. And that'll uh that'll help me
with my question. So, so you're saying
cuz there are other references from my
research that a few of the assertions
made in the Quran are from the
Apocryphal Gospels. Um, there's a couple
that I that don't come to mind now. I'd
have to go back and look at them. But,
but my question is when the Quran says
that it affirms or confirms what came
before it, uh, and you say
>> Gospel of Barnabas. Yeah. I'm It's Yeah,
Gospel of Barnabas. Sorry, man. That's
it. I'm tired.
>> What do you mean gospel of Barnabas?
What are you saying?
>> So, the Gospel of Barnabas is what
you're referring to that has it
appearing that Jesus was crucified. It's
that's the Gospel of Barnabas, which is
a 13th to 15th century forgery.
Okay. It came up for me on uh on Google
search as the Gospel of Thomas. So, I I
I understand that that's not really
in-depth research, and I I I appreciate
that the Gospel of Barnabas,
this is what says that Jesus was not uh
crucified.
>> Yeah, that's the one that says.
>> Yeah.
>> And and as far as you know, are there
any uh apocryphal gospels? You said the
Ebianite one does not count. Uh are
there any apocryphal gospels that say
Jesus is not the son of God?
early second or third century gospels?
>> Not not that I know of.
Yeah, from my search it gave me the
gospel of the Ebianites, but you're
you're in contention with that and I'd
appreciate which just means I have to
look into it further, but I think that
the the question bears asking anyway. Um
I understand that in the Arabian or
Middle Eastern world that these
apocryphal scriptures were widespread uh
during the sixth 7th 8th centuries. So,
and they were accessible and not as much
considered apocryphal as we consider
them today, but acceptable.
>> They were they were never accepted by
the church.
>> Well, not by not by the church per se,
but in the Arabian world with a what we
would consider a uh what kind of church
would we consider that? Not as um
Orthodox.
>> Yeah. You have
you have heretics that are that were
around. Yes, you have heretics that were
around. So what that that would that
would just that that diminishes Islam
even more if it's appealing to books by
heretics and saying that these books are
true. But like notice I don't I don't
negate that the Quran appeals to gnostic
gospels. I I I believe it does. It has
Gnostic sources in it. You know, Jesus
creating a bird from clay and all that
kind of stuff. speak speaking from the
cradle. Um you know all this kind of all
this kind of stuff. These are from
Gnostic stories, Gnostic writings. And
so um the Quran is appealing to
uh forged forged books as if they are
revelation of God. And so that that's
also a disservice to the Quran.
>> I understand. And the the the the
question becomes, are they accepting
what what a lot of people consider
apocryphal books as perhaps just
dismissed or outright considered heretic
by a certain uh group, but may consider
>> they're straight up forgeries. Thomas
didn't write none of that. Mary
Magdalene didn't write anything. Uh
Peter didn't write what what they're
saying he wrote. You know, Thomas and
yada yada. And then and then obviously
the last one, Barnabas, they're they're
slapping these names on these documents
to give them credibility
and the church that
>> uh understood. And and the question
remains when we say that the the the
Quran says it confirms the gospel. How
do you know specifically that it is
indeed the 66 books that you are
referring to and not necessarily any of
these apocryphal books that you would
consider heretic in that they may not
have uh considered heretic or the writer
of the Quran may not be heretic.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm not saying I'm not
negating that the Quran affirms the
heretical Gnostic gospels as well. I'm
saying all I I would hold the position
that the Quran doesn't know which is
like actually the true gospel and
encompasses all of them as the angel as
the gospel because it pulls from all of
them. It pulls from the Gnostic sources.
It pulls from uh Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John, right? And even when you go
into like the early sources of Islam,
when you go into like the life of
Muhammad by um Ibn Ashak in in that
book, in Muhammad's biography,
it says that John wrote the Gospel of
Jesus,
right? And then he even quotes from it
or tries to paraphrase the pariclete
verses when Jesus talks about the
comforter coming after him and they try
to apply that to Muhammad. So even in
early Islam it acknowledged the New
Testament that we have as the gospel
that Jesus was going around preaching
and that his apostles wrote and the
Quran also very clearly pulls from the
Gnostic Gospels as well. So
>> when you say confirm the gospel, the New
Testament that we have as in what are
those? Uh I know there are 66 books in
the Bible. How many of those are in the
New Testament? And how do you know
specifically it's refer 27? So you're
saying when it's referring to the
gospel, it's referring to these 27 books
specifically and nothing that is
considered currently apocryphal. I I
think that it's referring to the New
Testament and it it's referring to the
Gnostic sources. I think it's doing both
not either.
>> So the so the Quran only contradicts the
New Testament in so much as the
apocryphal gospels contradict the old
the new testament those 27 books.
>> Yeah. And then the Quran also
contradicts uh some of the apocrypha or
the gnostic gospels as well but in
certain places but yeah
>> right but in these places where it
teaches that Jesus is not the son of god
he is was not crucified those ones you
mentioned about speaking out of the womb
and there's another one that you
mentioned in are from the apocrypha
>> right so when the Quran says it's
confirming the gospels
>> is it fair to say is it Fair to say when
the Quran says it's confirmed the
gospels, it's it's meaning more than the
27 books you're referring to. But there
are things outside of the gospel that
the Quran or the writers of the Quran
may have accepted as gospel or in jail
that you don't.
>> I feel like you're not listening to me.
>> I'm sorry.
>> It's okay. I need I need you to
>> That's okay. What am I What am I
missing, brother? I apologize. I I I do
get that a lot. So
>> So just listen carefully. what I'm
saying. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So, as I said prior,
I believe that the Quran
is not just referring to the New
Testament, but is also referring to and
clinging to the Gnostic sources as well.
I don't think it's either or. It's both
and.
>> Okay.
Okay.
>> Okay. Um so, so yeah. So, we agree then.
I I think we uh you would agree that the
the Quran only um
uh contradicts the gospel as much in as
much as the apocrypha
do. And I think he said that it also
contradicts the apocrypha.
No, not just in the ways that the that
the Gnostics gospels do, but in the
Quran in its own unique way because you
don't see that they you don't see in the
Gnostics uh uh denying the deity of
Christ. They affirm the deity of Christ.
They they deny his humanity. The Quran
is saying that Jesus wasn't divine. He
was only a human. Nothing but a
messenger.
See? So like the Gnostics, they had a
belief and you'll you you can see this
in their books. They had a very mystical
secret kind of knowledge belief um that
everything in the material world,
anything in the physical world was evil.
But it's it was the spiritual that was
good. So they didn't believe that Jesus
truly took on human flesh, like
humanity, a human nature.
Okay? So they denied his humanity. The
Quran affirms his humanity but denies
his divinity.
So,
>> okay. So, there are things that the
Quran agrees with the apocrypha and
others that it that it disagrees.
>> Um perhaps in the same way with the New
Testament, there may be things it agrees
with and disagrees.
>> Exactly.
Exactly.
>> Okay. Um well uh from that perspective I
suppose I can see the argument from the
Quran's or the believers in the Quran's
perspective that they may have a more um
correct compilation
of the scriptures
than what we have as far as the truth is
concerned.
>> Is that fair?
uh based on their perspective of what is
true from those from those books that we
consider Apocrypha and what is compiled
from Paul and the
>> rest who who are you saying who are you
saying specifically has the truth?
>> Well, I'm not saying anyone does. I'm
just asking the question of from the
perspective of the the those who believe
that the Quran is true. It could be that
they're saying that based on the the
Quran uh their understanding of what
they they have taken from both the
Apocrypha and the New Testament as true.
They're saying this is what's left out
and this is what is true and that's what
they're considering the in jail the
gospel. So their gospel may include
those apocryphal teachings that your
gospel doesn't. Well, that that would be
wrong because even the Quran and the
Hadith point to Muhammad's relations and
his companions relations with the
Ethiopian Christians
and the
uh the Islamic sources call the
Ethiopians the people of the book. It
calls them believers and they have what
I have and they reject all the Gnostic
sources, all the Gnostic writings. They
reject all of that. They had Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John. The writings of
Paul, right? So, um, you can you can
look into what is called the Germa
Gospels.
G A R I M A, the GMA Gospels. Those are
the New Testament, the Ethiopian New
Testament manuscripts that existed
before Muhammad's time. that. And so
when Muhammad is around and his
companions are around, they're having
conversations and engagements with the
Ethiopian Christians, visiting their
churches and stuff like that and calling
them believers.
>> Okay. Uh uh so you're saying that they
only considered these Ethiopians the
true believers. What about the Gnostic
writings that were around in their time
and they were have access to
>> saying that they only said that they
were the Christians. I'm not saying that
they considered them only to be the
Christians. I'm saying that they were
identified as Christians by the Muslims.
They were a group that were identified
as the believers. So that would mean
that what the Ethiopians had i.e.
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John was
identified as the ine which is what we
have in the Islamic sources identifying
it.
>> Okay. But in but but being that the
Ethiopians would not have had the idea
of Jesus not being the son uh not have
being crucified
uh and not being a part of their
so-called in jail then that means that
the is the mus the the Quranic writers
would have considered
outside what was outside of the
Ethiopian teachings as a part of the NGO
even though the Ethiopians didn't teach
that they considered them a part of the
Christian community, but they were not
they did not limit the Christian
community to the Ethiopian teachings,
>> right? They did not limit them limited
to the Ethiopian teachings,
>> right? So, so they wouldn't
>> that's what creates really quick
sunshine that's what creates this big
mess is that you have the Christian
community identified by the Muslims as a
mixed group of you got the orthodox Musl
Christians and then you have the
heretics and gnostics.
So this is why this is the problem your
the uh not your Quran but this is the
problem the Quran creates. The Quran
creates this issue because it's
appealing to both Gnostic sources that
are clear forgeries, historic forgeries,
and um and actual Christians, or the
Orthodox Christians, the Ethiopians.
So,
the Quran, it's it's amazing. The author
of the Quran didn't know which was
which, man. It did it didn't know which
was which is why you see the mistakes
that the Quran makes.
>> So in that it did not know which is
which. It is not fair to limit the Quran
when it says it confirms the gospel of
the angel. It's not fair to limit it to
the 27 books of the New Test or the 66
of the the Bible cuz like you said they
didn't know which was which. So it's not
fair to really limit them to that.
Right.
>> I already said that. How are you not how
are you not following? I already said
>> no no perhaps perhaps I'm just restating
that. Uh but I I think I do understand.
>> Okay. So yeah, so the problem is still
is is still there. The problem is
actually it gets worse if we're
acknowledging the Gnostic texts. It gets
worse including that. So
>> I understand, brother. Um well that's
all I got. Um yeah, I'd like to I would
have liked to consider the name Jesus.
You had mentioned uh Jesus as name and
you mentioned someone else who had
discussed it but I had also um was
>> it's his name is inspiring philosophy is
the name Jesus
>> is Jesus not simply in the English
translation Joshua
>> it can't be that I think
>> well that's right so I'm not sure why
there's a transliteration of of his name
from the from the Greek to Latin to the
English. This is a whole little Just
check out just check out inspiring
philosophy. He breaks it down.
>> Okay, we'll do.
>> All right, take care, man.
>> All right, brother God logic. Thank you,
brother. It's been an honor. Thank you.
God bless.